in Tehran the roads are perilous but
anti-government protests are far more
dangerous
that's why people chose unconventional
ways to commemorate the life of mohsen
shikari the first protester to be
executed by the regime
the mullers are losing patience with the
protesters so this Revolt is moving
online
it's painful it's burning says this
student
who was shot in the eye during a protest
in Tehran
she posted a video of herself in the
recovery room hashtag you targeted my
eye but my heart is still beating along
with considered pictures of her recovery
her social media page turned into a tool
to challenge the regime all of the
evidence gathered for the crimes
committed by the Islamic Republic the
murders they've committed has relied on
social media and the internet
members of Iran's notorious
revolutionary guard or irgc have been
singled out on the internet for the
brutal treatment of peaceful protesters
on the 9th of January hashtag irgc
terrorists was tweeted more than 320
000 times a response it seems to the
execution of several protesters two days
earlier and its game momentum it
reappears 2.7 million times on the 15th
and 16th of January that after the
execution of British Iranian National
alireza akbari another phrase We
Iranians have surged appearing more
frequently than it did at the beginning
of the protests in September
and the regime has caught on look at
this do execute in Farsi a pro-death
penalty hashtag circulated by the
government and its friends there's a
brief spike in November but it hasn't
performed that well since
there are campaigns that we see are
clearly associated with the Islamic
Republic its supporters and its various
different institutions so they have been
trying to you know use use these
platforms to their own advantage in this
kind of narrative War
the protesters have won support
worldwide a hashtag campaign promoting
this rally in Strasbourg but will their
efforts weaken the regime
John Sparks Sky News